so today we're gonna play for you my
interview with a Democratic congressman
Tim Ryan I interviewed him at Netroots
nation in New Orleans Louisiana about 10
days ago very interesting guy and here's
as I've reflected on this interview that
we're about to play here's the question
I want you to think about as you listen
to and watch this interview is Tim Ryan
one of the good guys does he strike you
as one of the Democrats in the house
that is actually on the ball when it
comes to the realities of our politics
work focusing on the right things and
and informed in a way that is useful for
the progressive move of the Democratic
Party or do you think he's just another
one of these corporate Democrats think
about that as we check out this
interview from Netroots nation 2018 in
New Orleans Louisiana with congressman
Tim Ryan
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm here with congressman Tim Ryan who
is like everybody up for re-election
because the elections are every two
years do you think that this system of
two-year terms
serves the voters the best might might
sort of thought process on this for a
while has been your campaigning a lot of
the time having to raise money a lot of
the time just by virtue of it being a
two-year term I think there might be a
better way to arrange that or do you
think the voters are best served by this
system well it's self-serving to say we
should do four-year terms I do think in
this environment that may be worth
exploring but the main problem is the
money I think we need to move to a
public public finance election system
where each candidate gets certain amount
of money I think we limit the amount of
time so it's only a couple months like
they do in Europe and then you run hard
you knock on doors you put a campaign
together the country talks about it but
if you don't get the money out you're
gonna be spending four years raising
money and people just raise more money
and I think you'll just it'll eat up
just the same amount of time I think
there's sort of like three meta issues
and you name one of them right now at
whether you care about education or LGBT
rights or whatever you've got campaign
finance Internet freedom net neutrality
since that impacts coverage of whatever
issue is important and climate change
because if we destroy the planet it's
gonna be hard to lobby for LGBT rights
or whatever else the people that are in
power were elected by the system that we
have so fundamentally it's not really in
their interest to change that system
right so how do we break that because
you get somebody who says I want to
change the system they get in with the
system we have that's the system that
keeps them in so how can we sort of
shake that up well I think we need to
organize around those principles and so
I think we talked about as a leading
issue publicly financed elections like
that will pull the rug out from the
issue that we're facing with climate
because all of a sudden the moneyed
interests and that are behind that won't
have the influence over the political
system anymore and I think also finding
a way to talk about climate in the way
that that surrounds growth
in the economy you know wind and solar
jobs are growing at 25 or 30 percent a
year so how do we talk about that in a
way that says hey a portion of that
growth has to go to distress communities
has to go to old coal country old steel
country or rubber country like a lot of
the areas that I represent in the south
so that people will feel a part of that
new economy we also need when you can't
talk about climate without talking about
agriculture and that a regenerative
agriculture cent the sustainable
agriculture a big component of
sequestering carbon and getting us
healthy food which will drive down
healthcare costs so these are all
interconnected as you know but the money
is the real impediment because it
empowers forces that aren't always in it
for the common good food seems like
negative externality is sort of the the
key element that's missing from a lot of
the talking point discussions about
issues like for example with health care
for all whether you support it or not or
single-payer universal the idea that
I've got to pay for somebody else's
healthcare well you know crime goes down
when people have more care people make
better decisions about what job they're
going to take that actually aligns with
their values when they don't have to
stay in a job only to keep care how can
we that's it's it's simple but it's also
complex when you have corporate media
with four-minute interview segments
right so like what's a way to start
talking about that concept of negative
externalities in a way that doesn't have
like a glaze over effect yeah I thought
well I think you just started that
process I talked about the Medicare for
all which I've been a coach monster of
since 2007 and then we just recently
started a medicare-for-all caucus this
is a pro-business move you know the one
thing I hear from businesses all over
the country is health care what do I
hear from my friends in labor but they
have to negotiate about all the time
health care get that off the books let's
provide some certainty for the next five
or ten years you're gonna know exactly
what you're paying in health care so the
business could if they wanted to
negotiate or give their employees more
basically a supplemental and Medicare
Advantage style thing that they could
negotiate so they can have more
great fine do that but we want you
focusing on job jobs job creation
pensions put money in people's pensions
and wages and getting wages up and if we
can grow the economy by talking about
Medicare for all so I think we take it
head-on we don't sit here and just say
well it'd be nice for you to have it and
they'll be less crime and you know I may
not live in a neighborhood full of crime
sure no I may not care about you frankly
I mean I care about you but you know
somebody made an eidetic type of
ethically right allegedly but if you're
if you're telling a business person this
is going to be good for your business
good for employees but for your family
then that's a much better argument more
potent argument which I would like to
see I start making I saw Pete
D'Alessandro who was a Bernie's campaign
person in Iowa I went campaign for him a
little bit he was talking about Medicare
for all in the context of saving
capitalism and growing the economy and I
think that's a really potent argument
for us to make taxes so we have in the
House Democrats sort of because of
gerrymandering and the urban-rural
divide or at a mathematical disadvantage
in the Senate just because you've been
in the Senate you know one third of the
seats are up each election and it's not
actually the best setup right now for
Democrats but hypothetically taking
control of one or both of those houses
would you support or introduce
legislation to undo the changes to the
tax code that Donald Trump's
administration has put in place yes I
would I would keep the middle-class tax
cuts and even find a way to maybe expand
them I'm on a bill with ROH Khanna to
expand the Earned Income Tax Credit
which would put a lot of money back in
the pockets of working-class people
I think that's what we would do but
we've we do need tax reform you know the
the corporate tax is a joke I mean it it
affects workers and a you know a fifth
of them don't pay any tax at all so
we've got to find a whole new way to
capture the income concentration that's
happened in the United States and and
that maybe there's a billionaire tax you
know obviously raise the top tax rate
but I think we've got to provide some
relief
middle-class cuz they're just they're
still not getting ahead we saw just
recently wages went up I think two point
nine percent inflation went up three
percent right so we're still not closing
the gap on income inequality is actually
growing so we've got to provide tax
relief I think in the short term for
those folks and I think getting rid of
this joke of a tax whatever it was it
was not reformed it was basically
supply-side economics around three where
would you put the top tax rate and where
would that bracket start I don't know I
mean we'd have to you can't I don't
think you can look at this is like one
it certainly has to go up okay I mean
it's it you know the the the main
talking point was it should go back up
to the clinton-era levels which is
almost 40 right so you know I think
depending on what the other taxes you
put in place you know do you talk about
a carbon tax you know as we're dealing
with climate change is that part of the
package or what are you doing with
barrels of oil is that something that
you're gonna do which would all kind of
fit together so it's hard to say but
clearly the main economic issue we have
today is the concentration of wealth in
the hands of a few eighty percent of the
people are struggling they see the stock
market go up they see unemployment rates
go down they see the GDP growth happen
that's for 20 percent those those
indicators don't mean anything that
someone in Youngstown Ohio at this point
right so you can't you can't say what
this level will be at at level B without
the whole context but we've got to
figure out how to get to this
concentration of wealth and make the
investments back into a country we need
to make the sort of other side of this
or it's not even really the other side
but it's related as debt and deficit
yeah and I've read a lot about sort of
your your positions over the years and
maybe some have changed on undetonated
I get a little concerned when I see
Democrats talk about debt and deficit in
the same terms that Republicans do but
merely with a sort of different
perspective because increasingly with
modern monetary theory and sort of this
understanding that deficit in and of
itself isn't necessarily bad depending
on why we're increasing the deficit if
that's what we're doing right
do you think that the debt and deficit
issue is a winning one for Democrats or
are they just playing into an argument
that the the right has framed in a way
that it can't really be won on those
terms I think it's an important issue
because it's the responsible thing to do
I agree with you borrowing money like we
do for our families you know
unfortunately now hopefully we can
change this too and have tuition-free
policies in the United States but
borrowing money to send your kid to
school for the most part up until
recently pretty good investment taking a
loan out them have a house a pretty good
investment car pretty good investment
get back and forth to work those are
investments that paid off
so borrowing money to rebuild the
country a pretty good investment you
know so those are the kind of things we
have to make but at the end of the day
I'm we're balancing the budget at some
point but when you have huge
concentrations of wealth and those
people are you know paying enough to
help us balance the budget yeah that's
the difference for your right to
identify that the Republicans use it as
a cynical ploy to say we got to balance
the budget so we're gonna squeeze social
programs that's what they do so they
just borrowed two point three trillion
for the new tax cut and we turn around a
week later and say hey we want to get
money for snap the Supplemental
Nutrition that what did they say do I
get that but even I mean when you say
you want to balance the budget why what
happens if you don't balance the budget
because there's a lot of you know
hyperinflation it's not totally clear
that depending on why the deficit is
going up the deficit can go up a hundred
million but if that hundred million goes
into for example health care which cuts
down on employee absenteeism which leads
to higher wage growth which the
government then gets a piece of it's not
so cut and dry to me that just balancing
the budget for its own sake is a winning
talking point I don't mind having
borrowing some money just like we do in
our homes if therefore good investments
but at the end of the day big deficits
like the ones we're gonna have we're
gonna have about you know a trillion
dollar deficit here in the next year and
it's gonna run into the future they're
adding a trillion dollars and then
paying interest on that is a problem and
then when you're paying interest on that
and you borrowed the money from China
right and China's taking the interest
payments and they're building islands
and bases in Africa and investing in an
additive manufacturing advanced
manufacturing aerospace wind solar
high-speed rail and dislodging us from
from being economically competitive
that's and that's an another reason why
you don't want to be borrowing money
that seems like a stronger issue to me
then then balance for the sake of
balance right it's specifically why it
is when when the deficit goes up because
people who are mostly saving the money
as opposed to spending it or getting a
tax cut that that seems to be a stronger
argument but again it's like in four to
six minute corporate news interviews
you're just not going to get that sort
of level of nuance you're gonna get
anything you're not gonna get what do
you make of the split that it definitely
exists to some degree but I'm curious
what to what degree you think it exists
between this movement on the left to go
towards democratic socialism as opposed
to social democracy to the extent people
understand the difference I've been
talking a lot about there's some
confusion about those those two terms of
course democratic socialism be more
actual socialism social democracy more
the Swedish model is this a split on the
Left right now I'm hearing more about it
but I don't know enough to actually say
it's a split I mean you know clearly the
free enterprise system is broken right
now
you know we've lost the protections that
need to be in place on the environment
on workers on pensions on wages and all
these things that we've had in place
worked unions weakening unions which
were the main counterbalance to the free
enterprise system but I still think that
the free enterprise system for us in
America if it's fixed and well regulated
and operating the way it should with an
appropriate strong robust government to
fill in the knock off the rough edges of
the free enterprise system I still think
it's the best
for us in allocating resources but also
an innovation we are a country of
innovators and creators and
entrepreneurs the problem is all of that
wealth has got stuck basically in three
states venture capital money 80% of it
goes to three states California New York
in Massachusetts that's broken three
great states by the way phenomenal
states all vaalu but you know we need
that investment in Youngstown Ohio right
so the system is broke it's creating
wealth it's creating value and we
actually brought Silicon Valley 3:13
venture capitalists from Silicon Valley
to on a bus tour in Youngstown Akron
Detroit Flint in South Bend Indiana and
what they said when they got to our
areas they said there's things happen in
here that we didn't even know about
innovations creativity happening here
that can lead to job creation so the
idea is this free enterprise can work
but the capital is now stuck in these
three areas and in these wealthy pockets
throughout the country and then
concentrated to a larger degree that's
where you need strong public policy so
that's that's social democracy so if
someone said no I actually think we need
to socialize the means of production and
eliminate private ownership of business
and and make that social you would be
against that it sounds like if so what
you're advocating fixing the free
enterprise system but keeping them for
that social democracy if someone said I
want social to socialize the means of
production that's not something you
would be in favor no not at all okay
2018 midterms coming up at this point do
you believe that in in Ohio you know not
not always a red state but it's been a
key state for Republicans when they've
won at the national level how much is
Trump affecting races like yours or even
more local races like state Senate's and
legislators is a trump alignment helpful
is it a hindrance at this point or the
local races not really influenced by
that it's super helpful in a Republican
primary we're seeing that all over even
his tweets in Florida for the
gubernatorial primary
completely flipped the script there all
of a sudden Trump's candidate took off
not sure yet in a general I think
there's been a lot of softening and
we're gonna see in the special election
that's happening on Tuesday in just a
northern suburb of Columbus where our
candidate Danny O'Connor is
neck-and-neck now with a Republican in a
district that Trump won by 11 points
it's John Kasich old congressional
district so it's kind of a Rockefeller
Republican area a lot of immigrants from
Somalia and Bangladesh in that area
they're very tolerant strong LGBTQ
community slight slightly right a center
on probably some economic issues higher
income people
yeah but tolerant and and I think they
don't like the chaos violates their
Midwestern sensibilities and the race
baiting with LeBron James and in any
other black person he can stand up and
say oh look they're you know they're
dumb you know it just it violates kind
of who we are and so I think we're gonna
see a shift I really do that we're gonna
have a good year a good year congressman
Sam Ryan hopefully good for you anyway
and in November really appreciate thank
you thanks for having me pleasure yeah
[Music]
[Applause]